do you think Biden will stay in the race
look uh
I I watch him just like you do
and I think it's
almost inappropriate for me to say it
but I deal with other people I don't see
I don't see how it's possible and it's
not an age thing you know that I say I
have friends that are 88 89 92 Bernie
Marcus Home Depot is 95.
smart as hell as sharp as he was I mean
he's you know
mentally
Bernie Marcus Home Depot founder of Home
Depot one of the founders I mean I had a
meeting with him a few months ago he was
100 percent
I I know people that built their
fortunes from 80 to 90.
they were always struggling and they've
made a fortune from 80 to 90 a couple of
people in particular it's you know
amazing he's not too old you know his
age I think they do the age thing
because I'm four or five years behind
they say this is a way of getting Trump
let's go
but there's something wrong I saw his
answer today
on television about whether or not he
was going to run to a very nice guy
named Al Roker
when you can't get us off to a question
then that that was a long answer
talking about the eggs and this and that
look
I don't think he can
but say what you want they didn't expect
him to get it yeah people could say
he won an election you know they it
always goes I got the most votes of any
person any sitting president in history
I was told if I got 15 million less I
couldn't lose
they're surrounded by vicious smart
people
radical left people
but they're very smart and they're very
vicious
it's not him
he's now in Ireland he's not going to
have a news conference when the world is
exploding
I own property in Ireland I'm not going
to Ireland the world is exploding around
us
you could end up in a third world war
and this guy's going to be in Ireland
and not having a news go he hasn't had a
news conference I guess in months I saw
today where yes it's been we can't
so if he doesn't run if he's taken out
by his own party or who knows what
happens but it doesn't seem like he's
capable of running again who does run
well
obviously the one that they would talk
about would be the vice president Kamala
that would be the one that they talk
about
but I don't think she's performed well
on the big stage I mean maybe I'm wrong
but there are certain group of people
that will go crazy if it's not her
they're going to go very they're going
to be very angry if it's not her
that's a problem uh
you have a very ambitious guy in
California but he's done a terrible job
with the state I used to get along great
with him you know when I was President I
had a lot you know got along really good
Gavin
well you got along with Gavin news I did
I really did he was always very nice to
me said the greatest things he would say
things like he's doing a great job
oh he was about you not me that's why I
could never hit him because he was so
nice to me
it's just laying in weight right but I
could you know he was very nice to me
and relatively speaking some of them
weren't we did a good job for the
governors but
um they talk about him they talk about
some others
I just don't see
Biden doing it from a physical or a
mental staff yes I don't see it but it's
been a crazy period of time in the world
of politics
but he's surrounded by people you know
they expected Bernie to win
now Bernie's older than Biden you know
whether you like him or not he's sharp I
watched him being interviewed the other
day he's 100 sharp he hasn't lost much
if anything
Bernie Sanders
but you know he's older
so it's not an age thing I just don't
see him so they're trying to prevent you
from making it to the general election
by tying you up in lawsuits charging you
with crimes
you've described the process the old
Soviet process field Soviet process and
you've described it as illegitimate
if this goes to trial and you get
convicted like how would you respond in
the middle of a presidential campaign I
was so off the statute of limitations or
years off uh it's it's hard to believe
you know
usually when you have something like
this the Democrats say oh he's terrible
guilty the Democrats have even said
I'm innocent
I watched some of these I think it was
Andrew McCabe
the FBA guy who I fired
he came out he said they've got no case
they've all come out and said it
and then you've had
Andrew McCarthy you've had Jonathan
Turley Greg Jarrett
um their shoots all of them everybody
like and they're you know down the
middle people they see they say there's
no crime there's no there's no anything
think of it I've been through seven
years of both investigations seven years
they've looked at I have a very big
company much bigger than they understand
in fact when they finally got my taxes
they said whoa
you know they took them years to get the
taxes they got them that was the last
you ever heard you never heard one thing
about them
but took them years to get them because
they shouldn't be looking at my taxes I
was surprised the Supreme Court gave
them the right they shouldn't be looking
at people that's sort of another one of
the tenants you don't do that but I
didn't care that much I just on
principle I fought them
and they looked I built a great company
when you do the things that I do and you
employ thousands and thousands of people
over the years just thousands we've done
a great job
and then I ran for president people were
surprised that I won but I used to see
these rallies and I'll tell you the
rallies are bigger now that the
enthusiasm is more now than I've ever
seen
than I've ever seen so what do you think
since your poll numbers have risen
consistently since they rated this place
Mar-A-Lago well before they're ready in
August they were going up substantially
before they definitely moved since then
they've really been going up so
what how do you think
that your opponents will respond
I don't know how well we have two
opponents we have a primary opponent we
have a general election opponent I I
mean the Democratic party using the
legal system well what they're doing is
they're finding and think of this
they say 11 million pages but whatever
it is through all of these Democrats
investigations I had the mullah hoax I
had impeachment hoax number one
impeachment hooks number two Ukraine
Ukraine Ukraine Russia Russia Russia you
knew the Russia Russia Russia I got that
whole term from you Russia Russia Russia
you'd be screaming it I'd say this guy's
a comedian but you remember that whole
period of time quite well it turned out
to be a total fake but think of this you
know I tell the story very seldom but
because it's a sad story
so the russia-russia Russia hoax was
made up by crooked Hillary Clinton Adam
Schiff the DNC the Democrat Party the
dossier is a total fake thing we're
suing them now as you know on that we're
suing them a lot because unfortunately
uh Bill Barr didn't have the courage to
do what he should have done he should
have done he was so afraid of being
impeached so I have to do it civilly I
just have to sue people the justice
department should have done because
these are criminals but think of this so
you have all of these
millions and millions of pages
and they get you on a non-disclosure
agreement I mean I big numbers billions
and billions of dollars right
and they get you on a perfect
non-disclosure agreement where they get
yours nothing
a friend of mine who's a big business
guy said you have to be the most honest
guy in the world because with all of
those numbers that you have in those big
numbers
they don't have anything and you have to
see take a look at the people I just
mentioned look read what they said
there was no crime
in fact a lot of people are saying
he indicted somebody there's no crime
that's illegal to do
you know what he did so I don't see it
going I mean we'll have to see so but
just to bottom line it they I mean the
purpose of this is to keep you out of
the presidential race if I weren't
running or if I had bad poll numbers
let's say right and again remember the
Democrats are the party of
disinformation
if they want you to run if they want to
run against somebody they're going to go
the opposite for instance they don't
want to run against me and now I just
gave you a poll I'm nine points up on
Biden but they're the party of
disinformation so what they say is oh we
want to run against Trump
now they always do that you know they do
that and other people would do it but
they do it pretty much better than
others is there anything they could
throw at you legally that would convince
you to drop out of the race if you get
convicted in this case in New York no
I'd never dropped it's not my thing I
wouldn't do it
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from Tucker Carlson
tonight